you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
as europe records what could be its
highest ever temperature we ask how
cities are adapting to the new reality
nicola sturgeon urges the government to
reassess plans for a new oil field in
shetland ahead of cop26
and find out how artificial rocks are
being used to protect mexico's coastline
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
record temperatures are being broken
across the world with europe potentially
recording its hottest ever day
it comes as severe heat waves intensify
across much of southern europe and north
africa where we've witnessed so many
wildfires in recent weeks
it's expected the heat will impact spain
and portugal next authorities across the
mediterranean are warning people living
there to take extra precautions with
temperatures expected to stay above 40
degrees
and you can see on this map just how
high global temperatures are with most
of north america and large parts of
europe sweltering under intense heat
heat waves are a natural part of the
climate system however human-induced
global warming is making them stronger
and more frequent
so what does that mean for actual
temperatures
well syracuse in sicily reported
temperatures of 48.8 degrees celsius
yesterday which if confirmed by the
world meteorological organization would
beat the previous european high of 48
degrees celsius recorded in athens in
1977
and those temperatures were close to
being matched again as greece suffered
its worst heat waves in 30 years
temperatures there have peaked at 46.3
degrees
on tuesday the tunisian capital tunis
hit a record temperature of 49 degrees
breaking a 29-year record
so what's going on well the latest
heatwave in europe is being caused by an
anti-cyclone moving up from africa
an anti-cyclone is a high pressure
system which builds up over an area
as it builds up it causes hot air to
sink and that sinking acts as a heat
dome trapping hot air underneath it it
can stay there for days or even weeks
sally lockwood is in athens and sent
this report
[Music]
the intense heat dome from the sahara is
wreaking havoc across north africa and
now europe
as it moved northwards into italy
temperatures rose to dangerous new highs
the island of sicily already in a state
of emergency
has recorded europe's hottest ever
temperature of nearly 49 degrees celsius
greece still battling some of the worst
wildfires in its history
is now braced for more destruction
amid fears the heat dome will head this
way
the fires came within a few miles of
athens while they've been brought under
control officials can do nothing about
the temperature in the city
heat stress is impacting people's health
their ability to go about their lives
and many of those things that we rely on
to cool us down like air conditioning
exacerbate climate change
the images we saw in all the
international media will i hope be a
wake-up call for the global community in
that here there is something happening
that will lead us to absolute
destruction
and flooding now in turkey has destroyed
buildings and claimed lives the heat
wave caused deadly wildfires and now
deadly deluge it's a domino effect
when the air heats up it holds more
water more water to be evaporated so
that increases drought but of course
that water has to go somewhere and that
increases the heavy rain events as well
many are worried flooding and landslides
will follow in greece too
just one of many countries feeling the
relentless impact of climate change
sally lockwood sky news athens
well earlier i spoke to eleni miravilli
athens first chief heat officer and only
the second in the world i asked her
why the city needs one the heat chief
officers started as a collaboration
between
two cities first was
miami-dade and then it was athens with
the
arts rockefeller resilience center
and
we put together the extreme heat
resilience alliance
and we are preparing cities to help the
most vulnerable populations mostly
to
be pre to
to to handle heat to kind of to protect
them from extreme heat so why is athens
um a city that
is one is in the forefront of all this
athens is the hottest capital of europe
and um we know that the eastern
mediterranean is projected to have a two
degrees
uh increase
uh two degrees celsius increase until
the middle of the century
so
we really have to prepare for it
so what can be done to help protect the
city and its people from extreme heat
one of the main things that we have to
do is we have to raise awareness and
maybe one of the good things that has
come out of all these wildfires and the
very extreme temperatures of this year
is that uh people are have it more
clear in their in their um consciousness
that this is a very serious threat for
our for our well-being and for the
well-being of uh our people and and
their the the cities where they live in
so
[Music]
one very important thing is raising
awareness the second very important
thing is to getting the politicians to
to be brave about the different
policies and decision-making that they
they take from this point onward this it
has to be a much more horizontal
approach to policies that uh so that all
types of policy making has the concept
of
being resilient to heat
um the next thing would of course is
bringing nature into cities and making
sure that the nature
um that we
that that that that we have the type of
trees and we bring the
the water to the surfaces and we make
cities much more um
much greener because this is what really
brings temperatures down
and you can see more on this on our
website including how to survive a heat
wave head to sky news dot com slash
climate
in today's other climate news
a once in a century drought has lowered
the water level of a river that's vital
for exports in argentina nearly 80
percent of the country's farm exports
are loaded at piranha river but its
source in southern brazil has been hit
by drought for three years a 25
reduction in livestock feed exports has
been predicted affecting farms across
europe and southeast asia while hitting
the argentinian economy
the study by the environmental
protection agency has found that
increased rainfall due to climate change
will affect parts of ireland in
different ways analysis of the flow of
irish waterways shows that increased
rainfall is causing rivers in the west
to get heavier bringing with it the
increased threat of flooding and rising
temperatures will cause rivers in the
east to dry out increasing droughts
and a survey by the local government
association has found that 94 percent of
residents want to see increased
biodiversity in their area the lga found
that people want more tree planting and
for green spaces to be protected but the
group has warned a skills shortage could
be a barrier to councils increasing
biodiversity as only one-third of
planning authorities in england have
ecologists
scotland's first minister is urging the
uk government to reassess plans for a
new oil field near shetland following
pressure from campaigners nicola
sturgeon has written to the prime
minister saying he should reconsider
drilling licenses for the waters around
shetland where the cambod development is
due to be built will i speak to our
political correspondent joe pike so joe
remind us why this oil field is
controversial and what's the response
been it's controversial anna because
environmental campaigners estimate that
if it goes ahead we will see 132 million
tons of co2 released but it is slightly
more complicated than just stopping it
because the original license to explore
the site was given
20 years ago they're now looking for the
final go ahead boris johnson was in
scotland last week in the northeast of
scotland in fact and indicated he didn't
want to block it going ahead saying
quote we can't just rip up contracts in
contrast labour are against it want to
stop it completely where is nicolas
sturgeon this is taking place in
scotland she
is of course the first minister of that
country today she's written to boris
johnson as you say but merely saying
that he should reassess
that license and licenses in
similar situations now some accuser of
fence sitting certainly greenpeace are
unhappy saying she's deferring to the
prime minister this is a pr exercise but
others in the oil and gas industry in
scotland point out that it employs huge
numbers of people that hydrocarbons are
going to be necessary in the coming
decades and if you don't produce it here
and
employ people in scotland it will mean
importing it from other countries and
their economy is benefiting not ours
meanwhile the chancellor sunak has been
talking about the environment and
balancing uh the health of the planet
and the health of the uk economy this is
what he told sky news earlier look at
our track record over the past a couple
of decades we've grown the economy 75
and at the same time we've cut carbon
emissions by almost half so that shows
it's possible to do both things we can
become more prosperous as a country more
jobs more successful businesses more
money in our pockets whilst also
becoming greener and that's what we need
to do going forward as well certainly
though anna this letter from nicholas
sturgeon to boris johnson asking him to
reassess the decision on cambod does
palm more pressure on him especially in
advance of that cop 26 climate
conference in glasgow certainly that
event has meant there is far more
scrutiny on our political leaders when
they make these sorts of decisions
joe thank you
well we've heard a lot about the
challenges of tackling climate change so
let's hear now from people coming up
with smart solutions a team of british
engineers are growing artificial rocks
in the gulf of mexico to slow down the
effects of coastal erosion let's see how
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
the structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
the rock starts to grow immediately
we can actually
build a structure that has sufficient
mass and complexity to dampen the waves
that are passing over it and through it
you know obviously we're seeing the rock
growth that we want it's also quite
exciting to see the fish coming in and
actually using the structure
so we're hoping that these new
structures can actually become a very
although they're artificial a very
natural habitat for marine life for
example sea squid
our long-term hope is that we can make
these structures suitable so that the
corals actually attach onto them
and finally a company has discovered
that the geothermal waters in cornwall
have the highest concentration of
lithium in the world
geothermal engineering say they can
extract 4 000 tonnes of lithium each
year by 2026. the demand for lithium
essential for batteries is expected to
grow in the uk as more electric cars are
produced and that's everything from us
for today next time meet the woman on a
mission to protect forests in paraguay
you can see that tomorrow on the daily
climate show see you then
[Music]
you